peu
non
dit dont jacky êtes très vieille france
finalement c'est normal monsieur je suis
arménien vous faites
un collector
1 colette renard
[Musique]
jacqueline françois 1 jacqueline boyé
et vous voudriez que ça s'appelle
autrement qu'un pascal sevran monsieur
non
vous
le vieux piano de la plage de jouques
enfin quand fatigué le vieux piano de la
plage possède un là qui n'est pas gay
ainsi cassé qui se désole un me fanny
qui le console un doublé par grand
soleil du mois de juillet
mais quand il joue pour moi les airs
anciens que je préfère
un frisson d'autrefois en force alors
dans l'atmosphère d'un grand bal heures
dans une petite chambre
mon grand amour du mois sept mois oui
c'est souvient de tes vacances dans le
finistère chez sa grand mère c'est pas
chez ma grand mère était avec ma
grand-mère loctudy un petit village du
finistère ça se passait j'avais 6 7 ans
c'était très bref c'est très joli et
garde un bon souvenir
puis après ça va vite très vite dévié
vers le centre de la france qui sont là
mes vraies vacances d'enfance dans le
limousin près de prades images ton
limousin mon limousin ah oui là c'est le
petit citadin qui jouent aux paysans
quad en limousin je vais beaucoup les
étables je vais beaucoup les cochons
j'aimais beaucoup les canards j'ai
préparé la pâte et pour les cochons
oui j'aimais beaucoup ça avec mon nom
qu'il préparait les pommes de terre ça
sentait très bon et on mangeait à
l'époque les pommes de terre contre les
cuire dans du sel dans la pâte et les
cochons je me souviens de ça c'est un
rituel on mettait espèce de resservir de
la sueur de boiron malaxer c'est avec
les mains j'étais très content de ce
cérémonial et j'ai beaucoup aimé la vie
j'aime la ville
j'ai un bon équilibre avec la campagne
et quand je pense à la campagne c'est
forcément à la campagne de mon enfance
c'est à dire là et à partir de l'âge de
10 ans à peu près tu as commencé à aller
dans les bals dans les bals de campagne
à écouter l'accordéon et et c'est là qui
a pris ce goût pour la pour la vraie
chanson quoi on appelait ça la frairie
ça portait le nom de des fêtes locales
dans cette région est en effet dont ça
se passait dans les années 60 quoi et on
est privé des balles très charmant avec
des gens qu'on tanguay j'ai pas une
image de fraternité de gaieté avec le
son de l'accordéon qui symbolise pour
moi une sorte d'amitié jaurès est
gentille assez gai de quelle chanson tu
te souviens de l'époque dans ses balles
avec l'accordéon
les premières chansons à l'époque
c'était j'ai quitté mon cher pays la da
da da da da da da da da à détruire que
respirer d'accord c'est la mémoire de
ces moyens au vert mais c'est formidable
formule 1 dès que dès que je fais
chanter sale après midi à la télévision
il fois de temps en temps la france
s'écroule en larmes
on remet de bonheur c'est bien il n'en
faut aussi et 10 mois alors après il ya
eu bessines
vous voyez tout en père tenait un bar
tabac il a mon père avait été élevé dans
ce bar tabac et j'ai vu j'ai vu
apparaître là alors je retournais chez
la tante qui avait élevé mon père et
j'ai vu apparaître le premier jukebox
donc 59 alors là vraiment ça a été j'ai
tu resté collé devant ce qui se passait
c'est que tu es des donc dans le bar
mais en échange de quoi tu avais des
pièces de 20 centimes
et puis alors tu l'aimés tu évites dans
le jukebox et écoutez quoi emballer coup
à l'époque ont écouté alors vraiment les
toutes premières chansons de johnny
hallyday les bonnes plein de choses les
premières bons souvenirs souvenirs tout
le monde le sait et françoise hardy
toutes les premières chances sylvie
tomei copains alors je vois ça comme si
j'étais on écoutait aussi les dernières
chansons gloria lasso à l'époque mais
oui parce que c'était c'était très
ménagé lors y aller oui moi aussi
c'était très mélangée à l'époque je n'y
étais une jeune vedette loria souhaitait
une star david a commencé de très près
on écoutait bombe idowu on écoutait les
cloches de lisbonne
on écoutait étrangères au paradis à
gloria lasso alors étrangers aux parades
et tous s'en souvient rend ma main
car je suis étrangère ici d'un dans ce
pays bleu étrangers au paradis ap ap ap
ap ap ap venus venus mon ami
padilha
1 je suis à pas les paroles mais n'était
pas génial non il y avait aux vénus
les compagnons tous l'ont chanté dis
donc tu dis qu'à l'époque tous couché
avec ton transistors oui on a dressé
alors abattue rituellement sexuellement
c'est un bon début c'est vrai que chez
toi tu as 25 10 25 mille potash est
peut-être un peu beaucoup mais en tout
cas entre 15 et 20 milles sur la wii et
alors tous ces disques voyais étudiants
on a mené un seul sur une île déserte
elle quelle question impossible quand on
en a quinze mille m'enfin bon impossible
ce serait peut-être peut-être une
chanson de lucienne delyle peut être un
air d'accordéon jo privat une chanson de
trenet mais déjà je suis injuste parce
que des tas de choses mais je vais
oublier ou comme ça je partage avec
renaud legoux pour une chanson qui
s'appelle mon amant de saint-jean à
sachant qu'une impasse à moi qui il
aimait tant
bombay la vends mon amant de saint jean
un très joli un classique je vais faire
dans l'éducation ah oui ça va me prendre
en main oui très sérieuse c'est vrai que
tu as écrit pour dalida
il venait d'avoir 18 ans oui ça c'est
pas de l'intox mouais ça c'est de l'info
ça c'est d'un point c'est quoi les
paroles exactement il venait d'avoir 18
ans il était beau comme un enfant un
fort comme un homme s'est elle était
évidemment j'ai compté en le voyant mes
nuits d'automne j'ai mis de l'ordre à
mes cheveux un peu plus de noirs sur mes
yeux ça la fait rire quand il s'est
approché de moi j'aurais donné n'importe
quoi pour le séduire ça finit tristement
parce qu'elle s'aperçoit qu'à la 2 x 18
ans et c'est quelqu'un qui fait bien
connu le héros de la chanson relié à
l'époque oui oui sûrement dit danser
avec ton premier job de vacances c'était
garçon coiffeur je ne crois pas
absolument mais tu sais quand on a 15
ans comme ça et qu'on dit à sa mère et à
son père qu'on veut être écrivain
chanteur star de je ne sais quoi on vous
dit il vaut mieux apprendre un métier et
ma mère qui n'est pas stupide m'a dit
que ce serait peut-être bien tu coiffe
les voisines et apprennent un peu à
bettié et c'était pas content du tout
parce que ça m'a beaucoup servi
notamment service militaire
ah bon c'est a permis de ma part du
général ah oui c'était qui cette année
est là mais je m'étais bien l'arranger
site souvient de tes amours de vacances
où il fort ce forcément mais mes grands
souvenirs et ça va être terrible pour
toi ne sont pas sexuel je sais je suis
un peu mais je sais
tu dis quoi bon les vacances je
m'éloigne un peu du roman parce que on
avance on dans la vie je trouve que tous
les jours la vie est plus fort ni alors
le style des grands écrivains bon bien
sûr quand je veux relire un grand livre
relié des mots c'est banal ou des lignes
et des trucs des signes non je pense que
c'est un désordre voire mais les livres
politiques j'aime bien les pamphlets
j'admire aussi je viens de relire le
joual de claude mauriac récemment pas
mal quand même
j'aime bien ça à moi en parlant de
limier tu as eu le prix nimier ça
c'était vraiment c'était une des plus
grandes joies de tels oui oui mais c'est
normal
1 oui ça a été vraiment formidable
j'étais un jury magnifique mais très
fier là je le porte vraiment comme bien
sûr mais franchement tu penses pas que
latin peu choisi la facilité
parce que c'est très bien ce que tu
aimes enfin quand contenu le prix digne
et avec les honneurs on à vichy dancing
aussi prospects aurait dû continuer sa
belle mère dirait vous êtes fous au
petit garçon mais est ce que tu penses
que tu gâches un talent ben moi je me
laisse porter un peu aussi par la vie la
vie passe très vite
la télévision c'est le 17 on est venu me
chercher ça s'est fait par un concours
de circonstances je pensais pas atteint
la télévision je voulais écrire
peut-être un peu de radio mais pour
cette émission qui est venu je me suis
pris au jeu je me passionne car j'aime
passionnément la chanson et chaque jour
je me dis mais enfin faire toussaint en
effet je pense aussi à ça mais je ne
suis pas malheureux si j'étais
malheureux j'aurais arrêté
j'essaie de concilier deux c'est
impossible j'écrirai un jour on est
toujours virée à jour où l'eau de la
télévision donc que ça s'arrangera entre
chaque moment où je serai dirigera liten
chanson qui devient esprit là comme ça
je préfère la merde
que reste t-il
de nos amours que reste-t-il de c'est
beau jour une photo vieille photo de ma
jeunesse
que reste-t-il des billets doux des mois
d'avril
des rendez vous un souvenir qui me
poursuit sans cesse bonheur falling
cheveux au vent baisers volés rêve
mouvant que reste-t-il de tout cela
dites le moi
1 au bord de l'eau comme ça le soir tu
es parfait
[Musique]
pascal bonsoir alors on va faire une
hyper v vous savez ce que c'est une
hyper bio oui je vous ai regardé bon bah
vous êtes prêts à l'y fiable mais avant
de faire l'hyper bio je peu près à tous
que je suis prêt l'interview avant avant
de faire du permis ou ce avec le plateau
précédents ont parlé en parler des
femmes avec schirrhein ont étendu
jusqu'à sur la merveilleuse katchou qui
étaient avec nous vous les mecs à chaud
je rencontre contre elle très bien dit
ça parce que franchement il vaut mieux
alors alors non sur les femmes vous avez
déclaré
physiquement la fidélité physiquement
physiquement la fidélité est une énorme
plaisanterie vous croyez pas la fidélité
aux je fais une différence entre l'amour
physique à l'amour tout court et donc la
fidélité c'est celle de l'âme et du
coeur fait de fidélité physique je crois
pas c'est un peu d'hypocrisie
bon j'en dis ça pour robert hue parce
que d'un coup il a eu un fils est parti
il a été un peu non est un peu secoué
background faut pas mélanger
ça peut être mais l'amour peut se
concrétiser par la mort physique mais ce
n'est pas un tout l'amour c'est très
différent de la mort physique très rare
votre premier grand amour
madame il va pas tarder la boue ils
arrivent monique la rive alors votre
première annoncée vous monique votre
premier amour votre ami grand amour
s'appelait monique c'est quand vous
étiez une filière j'adore vous avez
trouvé tout cela oui c'est vrai ouais
c'était une fille de médecin au limousin
absolument et vous l'avez pas épouser
donc non ça et maintenant les mères de
famille à limoges
elle vit avec un journaliste à
l'immeuble était la retrouver parce que
je n'avais pas la la la la
non menu qui n'est pas l'arrivée non une
défaillance voilà si vous aviez pascal
si vous avez quelque chose dites moi qui
ai compris
si vous aviez quelque chose si vous
aviez quelque chose à dire à monique bon
attendez attendez attendez à quoi pascal
mais n'a pas revu monique depuis de
longues années
et là il va lui dire j'ai pas que cette
émission tellement sentimentale ce
rendez vous ce soir vous avez dit venez
vous a fait venir justement de deux maïs
vieillissant rollin pour parleurs de
chanson française dont on va parler de
la chanson du bonjour je me souviens
quand on avait 15 ans et qu'on allait se
produire le genre de son père de la
mêlée ravi j'aime la vie voilà voilà
monique passe comment on sait qu'elle
est ravie il avait ravi à son coach est
là elle prend 3 tard tu avais jamais
parlé de ce beau et bon alors maintenant
on va vraiment passé à l'hyper bio alors
pascal sevran c'est pas votre vrai nom
un nom c'est comment votre vrai nom jean
claude jours ouais on comprend qu'il ait
changé en même temps mort on me dit moi
c'est non c'est pas ça c'est le nom d'un
grand confort avec jean claude drouot
oui exact c'est pour ça que je changeais
à et en plus c'est le nom d'un grand
syndicaliste
oui ah oui ça j'étais léon jouhaux son
nom d'un général putschiste et vous êtes
chez contre la réhabilitation des
généraux putschistes vous avez ça vous a
pas plu quand on a réhabilité les
généraux putschistes et y avait un jour
oui je trouve que ce n'est pas urgent
ouais c'était d'ailleurs je sais je sais
bien plus traîner aurait pu chanter
c'est un jour go et on va y venir à
freiner alors votre vote surnom ces
nounous chez moi c'est ma mère et
j'adore mais c'est joli ça j'ai pas j'ai
passé j'ai passé l'âge quand même un bon
mais pour ma mère ça reste comme ça nul
chez lui chez ces mines à ses millions
du boucher alors vous avez atteint et
nous nous chez un peu dire enfin dire
prendront peut dire votre âge
si vous voulez hein si on attend l'avis
si vous n'en rajoutez pas on n'a pas dit
l'âge de she writes vous savez comme un
calage et la chaire à la 56 ans
[Rires]
soit 57
mais j'ai entendu des pertes sur des cv
m6 était vieille paire bon alors vous
avez 50 de oui et vous avez déclaré
c'est une phrase pas mal pour ça que je
la cite la jeunesse n'est pas une
supériorité c'est un avantage
oui donc ya pas de raison de la
jonquière d'avoir un nom il ya plus
aucun lien aucun mot burqa comme la
petite du banana split avec ses 12 ans
là bas vous êtes un écrivain vous êtes
écrivain et animateur télé vous êtes
chanteur et alors vous il ya un disque
je le montre à la caméra comme on fait
la télé pas dit ce qu'on n'était pas
venu pour ça mais si vous et moi mais
attendez moi je fais le boulot moi c'est
bien joué comme arthur attendez je
montre à la caméra comme ça puis voilà
c'est le dise de pascal voilà voilà
alors vos parents votre père était
chauffeur de taxi communiste et votre
mère travaille et chichi à paris qui est
une grande maison de couture donc dès le
départ vous aviez le goût du peuple et
le goût du luxe finalement c'est à cet
âge c'est très bien c'est là c'est vous
voilà j'ai pas vous dire qui vous êtes
enfin premier boulot c'était garçon
coiffeur
ouais hein ma mère avait trouvé que
c'était bien parce qu'à l'époque on vous
a service militaire et me dit comme ça
il t'emmerde rompt pas tu vas tu leur
couper les cheveux et arrive est très
bien vu aux idées de faire tuer à la
guerre ça tu feras le coiffeur donc je
coiffe et toutes les femmes de généraux
de la place de paris et alors alors oui
vous ai connus quand justement charles
trenet un jour charles trenet vous le
rencontrez vous invite à aix en provence
vous y allez et vous avez huit minutes
de retard et charles trenet qu'un
caractère je dirais que enfin votre
caractère et demi un côté sais rien
charles trenet huit minutes de retard il
s'était barré il m'avait donné
rendez-vous huit mois avant oui j'avais
un autre chez mon éditeur
vous savez je faisais mes premières
chansons et venez donc eu des
déconvenues
le 12 juillet à 12h05
et je trouve ça très bien cette
fantaisie des horaires comme ça mais
c'était huit mois avant et j'aime assez
la ponctualité donc je j'avais une toute
petite voiture et on est arrivé en
retard
aujourd'hui les gendarmes monsieur
trenet je vous attendrai devant la
gendarmerie et donc à la porte
on est allé voir les gendarmes pour 10
messieurs très n'attend jamais il est
parti voilà mais vous l'avez retrouvé au
bord de sa piscine quelques instants
plus tard quand il faut dire la bd j'en
avais vu mes livres il ya au moins un
animateur télévision qui sait lire bien
entendu et j'ai vu dans un de vos livres
que c'était pas séguéla qu'avait trouvé
la force tranquille mais léon blum voilà
et alors ça à part vous qui personne
jamais n'a relevé cela personne savait
même agacé françois mitterrand quand je
lui avais dit
fais comme ça mais oui c'est une phrase
de bloem le jour de son investiture sur
les marches de maths et bien entendu je
trouve ça extraordinaire
vous savez pour être animateur télé
c'est pas la peine de savoir lire c'est
peut-être pour ça alors bon vous êtes
toujours s'entraîner alors pascal sevran
vous êtes on peut le dire sans vous
vexer vous êtes un admirateur nez vous
admirez vous aimé admiré les gens je
vous interromps pour vous dire que quand
on a la prétention extraordinaire comme
vous et moi de le montrer dans les
caméras ça veut dire qu'on a quelques
prétentions à se faire regarder
peut-être pire est donc le mot la
moindre des humidités c'est nous-mêmes
d'amour une dose admiration il ya en
effet des artistes des écrivains et des
hommes et des femmes qui ne sont ni
artiste ni écrivain que j'ai admiré
oui je suis là et venir je suis capable
de beaucoup d'admiration il faut un
équilibre quand on a cet incroyable
mégalomanie qu'est la note de monter sur
scène vous admirez vous vous admirez des
gens qui par exemple mais je suis une
très grande fan de liza minnelli liza
minnelli vous c'est qui que vous admirez
le plus au monde le plus sombre de la
personne que vous admirez le plus là
vous me posez une drôle de question j'ai
jeu je sais pas un apparat par pascal
sevran
je sais pas il ya plein de gens jazeera
fidel castro non non enfin s'il ya
trente ans la troupe s'étirait redit son
rauque et les gentils et moi c'est
laurent ruquier et ses des bananes bio
vous admirez edith piaf a dit voilà
c'est clair moi une bonne chanteuse
travail du piano sera pas mal à paris
quand même alors que vous aimez admirer
c'est votre mère qui disait quand il
était petit pascal enfin une louche et
il cirait même les semelles de ses
chaussures
oui j'ai toujours été assez maniaque de
la propreté et la zorn
j'aime bien que ça soit en dehors du oui
est ce que vous êtes mire et xavier
gouyou-beauchamps fois énormément très
bien
je peux te dire qu'il aime vraiment
l'ordre parce que j'avais emmené mes
enfants sur son plateau pour l'équipe
c'est très désordre et je les ai renvoyé
dans la loge vip
d'ailleurs tout casser elle emmène ses
gosses par tous les jeux c'est bon aussi
pour les acteurs à elle les a même sur
elle est là et puis c'est que moi sur
une émission est là les faits elle était
due à l'effet sur mon plateau c'est
incroyable c'est que hardy sort accouche
les stars donc vous êtes vous admiriez
dalida ça c'est que c'est connu qui vous
a présenté à françois mitterrand après
vous avez aimé mitterrand vous avez
admiré mitterrand et vous dites j'aime
mitterrand pour ce qu'on lui reproche
j'ai aussi pour ce qu'on lui reproche
bonjour thierry 6 ici aussi pour ce
qu'on lui reproche dire qu'on voulait
c'est à dire que vous voulez mais aussi
pour brusquer pour la francisque et tout
ça oui si vous voulez qu'on fasse une
émission là dessus que je n'en fais pas
une émission je veux tenir la distance
oui oui absolument
c'est un homme que je l'aimé et admirer
avant de rencontrer et j'avais aimé
d'abord ses livres ce qu'ils disent la
manière de conduire sa vie et de
réfléchir alors je ne suis pas un
admirateur imbécile et béat
tout m'a pas toujours fait plaisir je
les écris dans un livre je sais mais ça
m'agace quand ce qu'ils ont mangé dans
sa main si longtemps trahissent la
gratitude et le lot commun
un jour je lui ai dit vous savez quand
même mitterrand il a fait écouter la
moitié du pays vous m'avez répondu c'est
normal pour un président de république
d'être à l'écouté des français
j'aime que vous citiez les bonnes
phrases mais j'aime vos bonnes c'est à
mourir de rire compris ton père écoute
comme non je les suis d'ailleurs très
vexés humiliés et m'appellent
directement ou non mais tous les ans fin
ça c'est pas très sérieux tout ça n'a
aucune importance
non mais vous êtes avec jacques chirac
jusqu'à ce que je peux dire si vous êtes
avec jacques lamquet qui étaient dans la
dernière émission d'une fidélité
inébranlable au président mitterrand
derrière cela coûtait la tête de la
liste européenne
moi j'ai la preuve en tout cas que
françois mitterrand écoutait tous les
français qu'est ce qu'on voudrait
exactement on voudrait que recueille que
jacques lang rni un homme à qui il doit
tout même qu'il admirait lui la première
pour une place sur une sur une liste si
c'était le cas ça n'est pas si tout ça
pour aller emmerder à strasbourg après
avoir écrit
dit ce que je pensais de cet homme là
que j'allais cracher sur sa tombe
ça n'est pas mon genre vous escaladez
vous grimpez toujours solutré ou pas on
l'a fait ben depuis qu'il est venu là
oui parce qu'il avait trouvé que c'était
bien puis voilà font quelques signes
comme ça de fidélité vous chantez plus
étoile des neiges à la fin des déjeuners
ces grands gag
oui en générant il aimait j'explique
mitterrand si nous on n'était pas invité
alors nous on y était avec pascal et et
mitterrand à la fin des déjeuners
il y avait rejoint hanna qui était
obligé de raconter la même histoire
c'était toujours la chemise lilas et
vous vous chantiez étoile des neiges que
quand il a commencé ses campagnes
électorales c'était une chanson à succès
et il me dit je me souviens que dans
tous les endroits où nous allions faire
des meetings les français à cette époque
chanter cette chanson là alors cela
amusait plongée relater ce petit
événement mais ça le faisait jouer rejet
raconte très bien il était très drôle
c'est un truc de famille très gentille
et voilà alors moi il me demandait
chanter j'avais pas atterré oublié les
paroles parce que notre angolais
je ne t'ai grand vallat et voyez quand
on donne une grande chanson populaire
c'est ça bon alors vous êtes on parlait
tout à l'heure d'animateur télé qui
savait lire ou pas les envoie en tous
les cas vous savez écrire parce que vous
avez écrit plein de romans dantin le
passé supplémentaire qui est le prix ni
mis en 79 et c c'est bien parce qu'il
n'ya pas beaucoup je rêve de la voir
depuis dix ans je n'ai jamais vous
l'avez si vous travaillez
il faudrait que je fasse moi noté les
écrire là il faut les écrire c'est ça
suffit pas de les recopier il faut les
écrire alors en train d'écrire son
prochain alors vous vous dites vous dit
j'écrirai vraiment parce qu'en ce moment
vous écrivez mais c'est difficile en
faisant le métier qu'on fait bien
entendu vous dites j'écrivais quand je
serai viré
et si vous n'êtes pas viré j'écris quand
même navrant j'ai créé tous les matins
et donc ils n'auront pas d'alibi alors
la chance aux chansons c'est tous les
après midi sur france 2 fait même quinze
ans ça fait 15 ans qui est une
institution
cette émission alors on vous doit la
nostalgie bon ça c'est un avis partagé
par tout le monde
ouais bergson dick sellerie hommage dit
que c'est la nostalgie voyait richard a
fredonné tout de suite la chanson
aouichaoui en faux pas il faut pas quel
que soit l'âge que l'on est
quel que soit l'âge que l'on est la
nostalgie est un auteur aussi pour
l'homme oui tout de suite
mais quelle que soit la sympathie des
attentats dans le passé supplémentaire
que dans le livre qu'ils prennent et mis
en 79 vous dit en parlant de la passion
du devis en parlant du personnage
principal vous dit
sa principale passion était pour les
chanteuses minable est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu dévoilé en écrivant ça
j'aurais pu trouver un adjectif un
objectif plus plus approprié
j'aime bien les chanteuse de beuglant
les chanteuses de bastringue des
chanteuses populaires toujours été ému
par st quand j'étais petit garçon
justement il y avait ces chanteuses un
peu ouais alors dernière question je
sais pas pourquoi vous détestez jane
birkin et vanessa paradis pourquoi il ya
longtemps qu'on me paye lançant il ya
longtemps qu'on ne me parle plus de ce
jeudi jean est détesté ta mots que
j'emploie très modérément pourquoi je le
resterai une femme aussi charmante que
jane birkin
sauf que si on me dit que c'est une
chanteuse l'a évidemment je tort un peu
le nez ouais mais c'est une femme d
c'est une femme délicieuse ravissante
c'est tout c'est lio elle trouvera pas
ce que je ferai mes clients alors lio je
craque devant elle quand je la vois donc
même enceinte et je lui laisse même
amené les gosses sur le plateau c'est
vous dire mes collaborateurs des
élaborateurs vous diront mais quand on
la voit plus belle que ça c'est pas
possible
très bien mais voilà c'était l'hyper
view donc maintenant bien connu
et bravo on peut l'applaudir parce que
moi j'aimerai pas être soumis à
l'interview unio plane laissé planer ses
enfants sur les plateaux de pascal
sevran il ya pas mal de grands mères %
d'occuper caen bc sa hausse au plateau
il ya des jeunes gens ça vous plairait
mots pour mon cher laurent c'est
vraiment cher pascal que vous savez les
choisir
bon vanessa paradis non vous n'en faut
il faut pas me faire dire des choses
méchantes je suis ce que je suis gentil
simplement oui on parle de chances que
c'est quand on me demande quand on me
demandait si c'est j'ai dit ce que
j'avais à dire que j'aime bien qu'une
très gentiment je le crois je le pense
ça sent la terre vivante quand on menace
de chants religieux comme excuse et
quand on parle de chanteuse je pense à
quelqu'un d'autre
quelques-unes d'autres accords donc
après l'interview de pascal sevran on
passe au talk show alors coach au coach
aux chansons où en est la chanson parce
qu'en ce moment la chanson française est
envahie par les reprises une reprise
c'est quand on reprend un vieux succès
en la rangeant à peu et on va savoir si
les reprises c'est bien ou c'est pas
bien si les gens aiment ça aussi j'aime
pas ça et surtout qu'est ce que ça fait
aux jeunes auteurs compositeurs qui ont
du mal à s'exprimer
alors nous ont rejoint pour ce plateau
stéphane bonsoir alors stéphane ça fait
ça fait un moment ton déjà pas vu vous
êtes sur scène en ce moment vous êtes
aux coulisses 5 rue du mont-cenis de
caen à quand les 12 et 13 mars le 12 et
le 13 mars et par le 12 et 13 mars
depuis le mois de décembre je fais des
concerts tous les mois de concerts
autres concerts par mois pour montrer un
petit peu de de quoi je suis capable
donc de chanter parce que c'est le
métier que j'ai choisi et que j'aime et
vous avez l'air de dire sa tristement
c'est bien de champel est ou non j'aime
j'aime ce métier non je suis calme de
nature à c'est très bien c'est pas comme
moi alors donc il ya stephen il ya
thierry séchan bonsoir
et il ya rachid taha alors tiré dessus
alors thierry séchan vous êtes vous êtes
le frère de renaud et vous êtes encore
plus énervant de soissons vous ça je
vois c'est encore plus énervant que
votre frère
j'essaie mais vous y arrivez l'auteur
journaliste [ __ ] traducteur chanteur
parolier
alors j'ai fait des paroles d'ailleurs
c'est vrai pour julien clerc pour la
voie pour elsa mais vous avez déclaré je
refuse de devenir barbelivien et comme
je peux pas être otage il
je m'auto détruits et vous vous êtes
auto détruit d'ailleurs avec un certain
nombre de livres que je montre à la
caméra ça pour s'autodétruire êtes fort
qui s'appelle nos amis les chanteurs là
vous balancer sur tout le métier
vous parlez de pascal sevran et je vais
grandir du mal mais on le dit au sujet
de parce que non on vous dit non vous
dis pas du mal vie de pascal même bien
même si c'est pas forcément un cadeau
tu as dis ça mais je croyais que je ve
lu mes livres je les tiens j'avais pas
j'avais pas chercher mon côté livres il
a beaucoup de courage il entre il fait
très bien la hongrie à toi tu perds mais
oui il écrit très bien et il envoie pas
dire ce qu'il a envie de dire je suis à
80 % je pourrais cosigné ses livres je
trouve qu'ils sont courageux puis
entouré il sait très bien décrire et
donc c'est déjà une qualité sans vidal
réussite avoue profiter l'an ce moment
c'est génial et une veuve du rail la vie
aux victoires la semaine dernière 1 2 3
soleil s'est vendu à 500 mille
exemplaires vous vous lavez le disque là
laurent hallé d'autre part la voilà mais
ça c'est un petit single gérer la maison
mais voilà maintenant montrer le ouais
moi j'ai coutume de duras ira bien qui
rira le dernier parce que ouais parce
que non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une
espèce de d'effervescence le rail mais
c'est la cache la forêt quand même bien
espèce de demandes du coton regarde
profondément quand on regarde les médias
et ceux qui diffusent le rail n'a pas
beaucoup de radios de médias qui dit
plus haut il ya un côté c'est vrai très
peut-être un peu
trés trés soirée très coquin là ce soir
va écouter du rail tout ça mais en fait
les profondément il ya encore un
problème vis-à-vis de la langue arabe
c'est à dire que la g ne naît pas
véritablement diffusé d'une manière
générale
enfin allait falloir merde
ouais mais c'est comme la deuxième cette
reprise de cette baisse est la chanson
sardou qui l'attendait pascal sevran
c'est la chanson française la plus
reprise oui avec la deuxième c est
maintenant
oui il ya la droite vieillotte il ya
aussi les champs solaires comme colas
est il de nos amours la mer au moins 200
sont très laid comme que reste-t-il et
la mer et puis beaucoup d'autres mais
c'est le coup venu de citi en effet
c'est la plus reprise d'altis et et non
mais c'est remarquable chanson française
quand il ya une remarque à la chanson
française elle fait le tour du monde
parce que quand il garde sa spécificité
elle ne veut parier un singe et d'autres
c'est une très très bonne chanson mais
alors et alors ils l'ont fait l'an passé
ça est-ce que c'est pas un problème est
qu'elle jouit finalement les auteurs
compositeurs les jeunes auteurs qui
veulent que vous êtes un auteur
compositeur the bakery 500 chants russes
et les textes on en connaît deux jeux
les 498 outre ouais on connaît il venait
d'avoir 18 ans et c'est déjà pas mal à
se faire
oui mais j'ai fait beaucoup d'autres
choses eu la gentillesse peur de le dire
ne veux pas parler de ça
je voulais dire que une chanson c'est un
texte en france en tout cas et une
musique et donc
et quand les jeunes gens d'aujourd'hui
qui veulent faire de la musique seront
ce que c'est ça ira une chanson il doit
y avoir une musique
s'il n'y a pas de musique ça ne va pas
donc comme maintenant la plupart de ceux
qui veulent entendre de la musique n'en
font pas ça va pas on peut être dans son
époque on peut danser rythme
parfaitement mais faire de la musique
sans ça on fait autre chose
et alors pourquoi s'émouvoir sur ses
chansons qu'on vient de citer
il ya une mélodie il me le dit on la met
la main sur programme et on avait sur
les risques qu'on veut il ya une mélodie
pas ce que dit pascal c'est aujourd'hui
ici la plus des reprises c'est parce que
plus personne n'est capable d'écrire des
chansons s'excuser le moment en ce
moment à l'heure actuelle en france et
même nom il ya beaucoup plus de
créations beaucoup plus de musique à
vent s'est désolé mais attendez à
l'époque de johnny de claude françois
ils ont fait des reprises
oui les effets se sont fait connaître
comme si bien entendu il ya eu quand
même avec michel berger avec je n'avais
qu'à pas elle est quand même une époque
où la chanson française n'avait pas
besoin de faire des reprises pour faire
l'étude moi j'aime faire des reprises en
effet plein et tous et des hommages
qu'avant aux chansons qu'on aime et
défend leur donne véritablement un
souffle nouveau
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une demande de
la part de l'industrie est relayée par
part parlé par les radios qui préfèrent
quelque chose qui est déjà connue parce
qu'on fait des panels faut quand même le
dire c'est à dire qu'on appelle des gens
qu'on leur fait écouter un petit bout de
chanson pendant trois secondes dans
leurs faits et les gens et ben quand ils
connaissent ils font comme ça quand ils
connaissent pas ils font comme ça alors
on en est ce qu'on peut dire pardon
c'est ainsi qu'on peut dire concernant
lyon par exemple ces cas là pardon
elle a un disque lio que j'ai écouté
quand même passer des chansons dans
certaines émissions de ges produites qui
est prêt et bien les gens lui font faire
des best-of les gens lui disent lio tu
fais des best-of vous en êtes à votre
deuxième best of
oui exactement entre temps un album qui
s'appelait vent data room america
précieusement pression
voilà donc vraiment l'exemple d'un jeune
auteur compositeur
dur je pars dans ces durs non c'est bien
sûr que c'est pas dur dur c'est pas bon
il ya fort faut relativiser il ya des
choses plus dures dans l'existence bon
chanter là je me produis aux coulisses
bon effectivement j'essaie de monter sur
scène pour montrer aux gens aux
personnes notamment les les autres
personnes qui ont parlé sur moi donc de
soi disant que je elles ne connaissent
pas ce que je fais donc alors je chante
et vis-à-vis de tous les interprètes
comme avec rachid par les interprètes
français
moi je dis français dans la mesure où si
la langue française alors je suis arabe
aussi un homme aux arabes espagne tu
t'en fous toi mais moi je m'en fous pas
mal être je suis normand voyer une chose
une chose est claire quand je suis
interprète de la variété française bon
que vous dites il ya une pauvreté
qu'aujourd'hui il ya moins de
l'interprète
mais dans ce cas là que les que les gens
se déplacent au ski ce qui est pour moi
moi j'ai demandé à des gens de venir me
voir des à des journalistes des ils se
déplacent pas ils veulent pas se
déplacer
tu as eu ces chants par exemple stéphane
vous pensez qu'elle va y arriver que à
la raison de s'accrocher je suis
incapable de le dire très sincèrement je
n'ai pas avec tout ce qui a été dit et
je ne suis pas moi contre vous du tout
avec tout ce qui a été dit je peux vous
garantir que je vis aujourd'hui un vrai
préjudice moral et un préjudice
artistiques parfois pour tout artiste
pour tout artiste c'est simple de parler
bon pour un cheat rare il a sa maison de
disques il est tranquille il n'a pas été
attaquée par personne il a été attaqué
par personne il est tranquille moi j'ai
eu toute la pression le dos et j'ai eu
des artistes non j'ai eu des
dysfonctionnements
mais ceci dit dans le préjudice moral ya
un artiste il ya un individu est là qu
est là et il ya des producteurs ayant un
gros staff je suis le coton et lin début
du repas des producteurs
et bien moi je suis l'individu concerné
et l'individu avenant l'individu
concerné l'individu concerné il est là
et il a souffert en trois ans donc
pendant trois ans je vis ce préjudice
moral et je ne le vis pas seul je vis
avec un auteur je dirais qu'un
compositeur
je le dis avec toute une équipe et toute
une équipe ça déstabilise tout unique
lui peut dire stéphane pourquoi mais ça
directeurs stables j'étais un spectateur
je suis juif odeurs il a tué six roms
par le public
voilà merci je vais à expliquer aux
téléspectateurs parce que sinon personne
va comprendre c'est qu'effectivement il
ya eu un problème
en 1995 aux victoires de la musique
stéphen a été meilleure révélation de
l'année et on s'est aperçu que le
producteur de son disque était en même
temps le producteur de l'émission les
victoires de la musique c'est monsieur
denis limon donc ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'effectivement ça fait un
scandale parce que les gens ont dit il
n'est pas normal que le producteur du
disque de stan honey sur le même
producteur que l'émission et thierry
séchan ici présent a dit que c'était une
arnaque
voilà pourquoi vous êtes énervé on a
tous dit voilà alors j'explique aux gens
parce que sinon je veux atteindre
thierry un geste maladroit célèbre ses
20 ans qui rêvait des rires je n'ai
jamais entendu cette série c'est
étonnant oui vous avez dit c'est tout ce
que vous avez dit la génération lisais
dans le dictionnaire révélations le mot
révélation ce qui doit être révélé
méconnu du public
méconnu du public qu'elle vote il doit
fait connaître que la future j'ai retiré
la chose suivante c'est que gt gt dans
ce film un donc révélation j'ai été
nommée lauréate je gagne je n'ai pas moi
je sais pas je prends un prix je pars je
vais chanter je vais amener quelque
chose de gens je vais donner quelque
chose moi c'est pour donner c'est pour
donner du bonheur donner de la joie
je suis pas là pour pour me faire signer
je suis pas loin de ses bases et il
faudrait parler du système bons
souvenirs vous chantez une reprise oui
parce que j'adore d'ailleurs bon chemin
de la musique roi des cons superbe louis
gibert c'est comme une teneur une
reprise technique
absolument c'est énorme anglais ce qui
fait dire pour que les gens suivent en
temps de paix attendez pour que les gens
suivent donc ce qui s'est passé en même
temps va chanter trop d'en finir ce qui
s'est passé c'est donc à cet effet n'a
été accusée d' arnaque parle de place
par plein de gens d'ailleurs les
victoires de la musique non plus été
produite par la société qui la
produisent à l'époque à distribuer aux
gens et vous avez dit l'information qui
est fausse si je pensais pas le
producteur de musique il est
administrateur de la musique c'est
claude oui c'était le patron d'unison
d'annuler les deux côtés vous l'oubliez
oui et c'est que tous les auteurs
pointent à la ligne c'est tout et et
dennis lim on sait simplement il ya
disparu toute façon ce n'est plus mon
nouveau producteur sa belle soeur
valérie alors pour le public c'est
parfait c'est le patron dr cystéamine
ans pascal sevran vous avez vous
connaissez la faire vous avez quelque
chose
dire claire rien non j'accueille parce
qu'elle se vend
pascal sevran bonsoir bonsoir alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont très copains ils
ont fait de la prison tous les deux non
non jamel dans un film et
jean-christophe pour de vrai donc ça
crée des liens ils ont vidé qui
perdraient au change cet [ __ ] cratère
est à côté de ce trublion abbaoui
sembrancher qu'à se réveiller c'est êtes
vous l'homme curieux ambitieux et
cultivé à astrid en cherchant même et
bien sûr mais c'est bien merci merci
beaucoup à nous en vouloir
comment ça va ça va à l'époque de
françois mitterrand vous êtes vu
beaucoup j'imagine pas beaucoup non ah
bon pour voir j'ai vu beaucoup gilbern
on s'est croisé quelques fois mais ils
étaient moins souvent à solutré mais on
s'est croisés ouais je n'étais pas à
solutré salue très souvent l'étranger
oui c'est pis dakota et c'est ce qu'ils
disent oui il était voilà le moins
mitterrand des mitterrand vous faisiez
partie de ce qu'on appelait les
mousquetaires du roi avec jack lang
pierre bergé kezman vous voyez toujours
les trois autres mousquetaires mais ça
s'est un peu distendu les liens non je
les vois bien sûr que j'étais très très
content d'être avec eux j'étais très
fier de ça oui mais aujourd'hui je les
vois souvent oui vous l'avez aider quand
il a été dans la merde là vous imaginez
bien je vais pas vous faire la
révélation ce soit de quoi que ce soit
je peux parler de ça ce soir
avant pourquoi pas ce que c'est pas
convenable j'ai rien à dire sur ce sujet
non mais il était en taule j'ai entendu
10,5 millions de francs voire est appelé
en disant moi je te file en supposant
cher thierry ardisson en supposant que
j'ai appelé way est ce que vous imaginez
que je vais vous dire ce soir que j'ai
appelé messi pour voix et ben non pas du
tout et tout le monde dit la vérité ici
oui moi aussi je vais à dire vous êtes
appelés pour mentir non mais vous savez
il ya beaucoup d'émissions de télévision
on parle beaucoup de tout le bien qu'on
fait toutes les belles choses qu'on fait
on veut parler de tout ça mais n'a rien
d'étrange et inferno non non non je veux
pas dire oui du tout j'ai rien dit
victime j'ai fait du bien c'est pas moi
en tout cas ce qu'ont posé la question
j'ai entendu
mais moi je n'aime pas beaucoup ça non
non voilà non mais qui rit je voudrais
pas du tout mais c'est pas un endroit
convenable ne peut pas être ces
choses-là bien moi je les adore c'est
vraiment parce qu'il est bon alors vous
avez gardez vous en tous les cas vous me
l'avez dit ça une grande amitié pour
françois mitterrand malgré les
révélations sur son passé vichyste et
son amitié avec bousquet vous avez
continué à être son ami mais attendez
faut pas prendre les grands mots
françois mitterrand a bien voulu que je
sois pas trop loin de lui et de sa
famille ce qui a été pour moi une grande
émotion d'une jeune homme que j'étais
très impressionné de voir un homme de
cette densité
moi j'ai respecté je respecte encore
françois mitterrand y compris pour ceux
qu'on lui reproche
nommé l'amitié avec bousquet par exemple
mais te d écouter les grands mots tous
est un duo notre époque
allez beaucoup bousquet voyez françois
mitterrand il avait la légion d'honneur
remise sa bouton il avait été blanchi en
avait d'ailleurs fait retirer vous savez
tout cela vous le faites redire alors je
le dis très tranquillement
françois mitterrand était tout sauf
antisémite françois mitterrand était
entouré de juifs magnifique j'ai eu dans
ma vie un maître à penser que ça plaît
emmanuel berl je ne suis troublé en rien
par le passé de françois mitterrand bien
alors vous vous l'avez appris quand sa
belle histoire de vichy le bouquin de
paix en tout ça je vais faire la même
réponse il s'évade trois fois il arrive
à vichy comme beaucoup de gens on les
accuse pas des fascistes
il est dit la vente quelques années il
est prisé de guerre évadés
il trouve il travaille dans un service
qui récupère les prisonniers évadés et
moins d'un an plus tard on le trouve
dans des réunions de de résistance bien
alors on va voir on va parler de votre
émission de télévision c'est comment on
fait comme ça
donc voilà donc vous revenez sur france
2 oui demain à 12h05
mais il s'appelle chanter la vie oui
c'était bien la peine de vous virer en
même temps ça vous en parlerai à vos
chefs thierry franchement tu aimes bien
vailati exagèrent je mettrais cantine et
que michèle cotta
moi je n'ai pas été fâché non j'aime
beaucoup je suis c'est un peu vinaigre
quand même non même pas parce que moi je
peux pas me déprendre du charme de
michèle cotta et puis j'ai beaucoup vu
c'est une grande journaliste alors
évidemment elle m'a eue au charme
ce n'était pas une bonne idée avec la
venue de charme mais oui donc moi dès
que je suis deux minutes et avec elle
c'est ce qu'ont fait les cons et de
mutek michèle cotta
on parle de françois mitterrand oui et
on en dit des choses gentilles alors la
première vous faites chez là c'est à
dire que dîtes moi en quoi c'est
défendre la chanson française
[Applaudissements]
c'est une je vais vous dire thierry
c'est une femme magnifique je trouvais
qu elle l était près de moi c'était bien
elle va chanter ce qui est plus original
elles ressentent que depuis trois ans
elle avait fait son retour sur france 2
dans mon émission
lorsqu'elle a chanté après ces lieux on
est devenu amis parce que c'est une
femme aussi bien je viens de le dire et
je lui des coûts devient on entrevoit la
télévision chanter et moi j'aime bien
être un peu décalé puis c'est pour
chanter en chorale entre catois elle a
très gentiment
elle va chanter une chanson de mouloudji
et une chanson de brassens en direct
avec les musiciens
alors là je trouve que c est d'accord
vous venez chez là mais vous lui faites
chanter au grand public et donc je
trouve que ce voile a cette chance que
j'avais envie d'avoir que une femme de
cette qualité à côté de moi pour le
premier jour
bon donc tout va bien enfin je parlais
du patrimoine chanson française il ya
beaucoup il ya beaucoup d'autres choses
il ya beaucoup de choses dans cette
émission si vous êtes réveillé vous
jettera mais je regarderai dans bien sûr
me suis réveillé dimanche mais quand
même c'est fini tout ça je me fais pas
c'est drucker m'avait dit si je serai à
la télé à michel m'avait dit il faut que
tu arrêtes de boire faut qu'ils arrêtent
de fumer
vous connaissez donc rien fait parce que
tu mange des pâtes dont je mange des
pâtes ne cherche les tout ce que tu dis
là kadri que je ferais pas ces tapis
rouge
bon donc voilà je t'ai under control
c'est demain voilà demain à midi puis ce
sera tous mes diplômes si tout va bien
voilà ça peut même mais ça va être une
autre tonalité parce qu'il ya jamais eu
à cette heure-là de variétés quoi alors
puis le public très mouvant il ya
beaucoup de gens en août génération qui
passe
voilà c'est un pari je vais le faire
très simplement avec montons à moi et
s'il ya des gens beaucoup qu'il regarde
très content donc on regarde tous pascal
sevran de oui c'est ça lui fera plaisir
mais sans frapper faire plaisir parce
qu'elles se vendent c'est important non
mais c'est vrai alors vous continuez à
écrire quand ma main tous les jours
c'est beaucoup plus courageux que moi à
oui ça je dise avant l'éditeur un vote
il faut trouver le temps un peu comme
vous faites c'est merveilleux d'arrivée
c'est à dire que je j'ai bien organisés
les trucs quoi je déjeune jambes je
déjeune pas ouais donc c'est déjà depuis
très longtemps
ça fait des économies ça fait mincir et
ça permet d'écrire oui c'est pas mal et
puis oui parce que chris est très
importante donc j'écrivais avant la
télévision j'écris pendant la télévision
j'écrive très probablement après et là
c'était un moyen d'expression différents
si on veut venir me trouver on vient me
trouver dans mes livres c'est un petit
peu différent et j'ai besoin de cet
équilibre entre le métier public où nous
sommes là en train de bavarder
joyeusement et puis le silence de
l'écriture qui compte beaucoup pour moi
mais ça marche les gens viennent vous
retrouver comme vous dites le dernier
bouquin je n'ai vendu combien 200 milles
c'est énorme et ça fait du pognon très
bien géré nos jalouses
oui mais vous avez raison oui on écrit
pour autre chose ainsi rien surtout est
et afyon suilhard plus surtout celui-là
sociaux
quand vous dites je publierai un nouveau
livre tous les 4 janvier oui jusqu'à ce
que je ne sois plus en état de le faire
c'est pas mal comme idée je pensais à ça
tous les 4 janvier on sait voilà c'est à
dire que le 5 janvier vous êtes invité
dans l'émission je me dis tout de suite
pourquoi le catch est pas c'est une date
anniversaire de la naissance de stéphane
donc j'arrive comme le premier league
est sorti comme ça c'était tu es jolie
je suis pas très fétichisme et jetons
etc
c'est un symbole quoi trouver que
c'était vous est remis de ce drame pour
vous non je suis content je chante et je
consommerai non mais vous avez l'air
comme
ça va ça va ça vous prenez sur vous ben
oui il faut se tenir convenablement son
sens montre pas la télévision et puis
les gens qui regardent sont contents
donc je suis en vie ouais c'est tout à
fait étonnant d'être en vie quoi alors
je de ce à quoi c'est pas mal le fait
d'être en vie c'est pas mal vous avez
aimé nager quand même ah oui hein je
suis content c'est bien le saint louis
oui c'est très très bien je suis comme
un fou je n'ai plus parlé du tout ouais
mais là c'est vrai pari la baule où là
je suis comme à là je suis preneur est à
l'arrêt ah oui c'est plus qu'on peut
imaginer cgt jamais aller avant mais je
voulais battre tout le temps là je suis
comme ouais comme un gamin qui joue avec
les bateaux sur la scène c'est très beau
et bien alors pascal sevran pour vous
changer les idées
ouais on va vous faire une interview
cauchemar savons par les bouches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes par les singles vais parler
par le bon nous recommençons l'accès par
laisser passer ces banques c'était ta
raison mais je suis comme ça mais j'ose
pas des foires fêtes ont fait pas lui
avoir été géré en fait on va le refaire
c'est un genre d'objets de leur faire il
a il a parlé ont valu attention on ne
bouge pas pendant ce temps là pour
l'heure le bouchon ne bouge pas pendant
le jingle
en le cauchemar dans les ting voilà un
séduisant c'est plus propre bien alors
voilà donc la table ou cauchemar le pire
truc hein le pire des accidents
conjugaux c'est de vous faire surprendre
par votre amant avec un autre de
surprendre votre amant avec votre
meilleure amie sinon le le pire
cauchemar c'est de trouver la personne
que l'on aime entre andry ravec
quelqu'un d'autre à 30 coucher ouais bon
c'est pas très grande et bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
et vous jamel et vous arriver de pire
c'est de vous faire surprendre par votre
amant avec un autre vous des surprendre
votre amour avec votre meilleure amie ne
marche pas avec vous le pire cadeau
qu'on puisse vous faire une perceuse
sans fil des vacances avec vanessa
paradis ou l'intégrale de y'a pas photo
en vidéo à l'intégrale de y'a pas photo
ça va loin la pire situation dans
laquelle vous pourriez vous trouvez
pascal sevran avoir une cigarette mais
pas de feu une carte bleue mais pas de
code
un mec sublime mais pas de préservatif
se doutait bien qu'avec vous salue c'est
le service public en même temps je me
dis ah oui c'est ça c'est le service
public cigarettes et pas de feu ouais
c'est une version à vous pour jean
christophe g aurier un pétard mais pas
trop
non lui c'est pas il les avale les
joints la pires désillusions ça serait
d'apprendre qu'il ya quelqu'un dans
casimir que thierry la fronde a mis une
chaussette dans son collant ou que
chirac est mêlé à la sphère des hlm de
paris que thierry la fronde la musique
mais le pire c'est un portable qui sonne
tout le temps ou qui sait jamais c'est
un portable qui sonne tout le temps ah
ouais c'est ça besoin qu'on vous appelle
toute la journée cette maladie terrible
touche ça comme leur sexe tout cas son
coucher ils maintiennent la bouche
ils parlent à leurs chiens sont tout le
temps face et un terrible tu es outils
signes extérieurs de détresse ah bravo
ça pourrit la vie mais c'est quand même
le pire c'est grandir seul vivre seul ou
vieillir seul vieillir seul à le pire
c'est de ne plus pouvoir toucher la
personne avec qui vous vivez ou de plus
vouloir la toucher a de plus pouvoir le
problème de rennes 7e et quasi revoir et
c'est une vision qui te met devant la
réalité de la vie est le pire quand on
est plaqué le pire c'est de l'apprendre
par une lettre un coup de fil ou par
quelqu'un ça m'est arrivé quelquefois
mais je savais avant donc que j'aurais
on ne m'apprend rien généralement dans
ce domaine le pire c'est d'apprendre que
dieu n'existe pas ou qu'il existe mais
que ce n'est pas le vôtre qu'il existe
et que c'est pas bien
djamel pascal sevran merci
merci parce qu'elles seront demain
12h05 chanter
à changer la vie mais
je m'en vais pourquoi ah bon je te
rester parce qu'il était à mon âge au
nom va rester je reste parce qu'un jour
c
[Applaudissements]
sur la terre
il a vu souvent la ffsa a été trop
je parlais cette étude offre avec le
pool s'appuyer sur cette touche enfin
est ce qu'on peut avoir un assistant oui
elle ce qu'elle caméline voilà mes
vignes tu viens tu as plus là dessus
voilà sois gentil parce que moi il faut
que j'interviewe pas dire si on lâche ça
fait quoi
merci tu suivras le doigt parce que
manger un truc ici qu'il gèle aussi
vient
pendant cinq ans
pas mal le même look très classique où
j'étais comme vous avez vous est
vachement bien karolina kurkova lui
mannequin de l'année je sais elle fait
toutes les coupes de vogue us elles sont
les regarde on comprend pourquoi
quelle est elle est sympa et tout elle a
toutes les qualités un allez tous les
ans c'est un petit peu un vous parler
français bonjour ma belle série très
beau j'adore
alors vous publié chez albin michel un
livre qui s'appelle lentement place de
l'église pascal sevran
[Musique]
le toit pour voir il faut l'aider c'est
comme ça faire quelque chose peut-être
maintenant livrée avec mon livre ouais
non pas le vôtre et site
oui et pardon non regarde le doigt tant
pis tant pis mais les vraies cela me
fait beaucoup rire bien alors ce livre
rend place de l'église
c'est le quatrième volet d'un journal
que vous avez commencé avec la vie sans
lui
deux cent mille exemplaires chacun ce
qui fait 800 milles 1 mille 1 à 4 alors
huit cent mille exemplaires pascal
sevran ça fait beaucoup d'argent non oui
mais ça fait beaucoup d'impôts d'accord
enfin vous avez quoi vous avez quand
même 15 20 francs par exemplaire non
j'ai pas demandé faudrait que je leur
demande
vous parlez en france vous êtes comme
moi vous êtes un peu rétro motion
thierry tu tues moi rétro que vous je
vais pas tourner en rond non mais
maintenant seriez vous avez des moyens
d'arrêter la télé ou pour y arrêter de
faire la télé là vous aussi non non j'ai
pas encore faire de la télé vous rigolez
non je disais ça parce que ça vous
aurait permis de sortir de votre
schizophrénie pascal sevran
à un moment dans votre livre lentement
place de l'église où vous êtes dans un
village de la france profonde
morterolles votre fameux morterolles
vous êtes dans le silence depuis huit
jours est en train d'écrire
et puis vous vous regarder chanter
danser à la télévision et et vous dites
le décalage entre mon personnage public
et moi est incompréhensible c'est
qu'avant vous reconnaissez pas sur
l'écran vous parlez de gouffre entre
l'homme des lumières est l'homme de
l'ombre celui de morterolles et il vous
dit à un moment c'était car tellement
deviendra insupportable
j'aime beaucoup la chanson donc je ne
renie pas du tout l'homme un peu
enthousiaste l'accordéon les vestes de
tintin ça fait rien très bien c'est moi
aussi abandonné un homme se rassemblent
au fil du temps je ne renie rien de cela
mais il est évident que quand je suis
dans mes province un petit peu comme ça
enfermé dans l'écriture qui compte aussi
beaucoup pour moi et dans le silence je
me regardais jeudi c'est
incompréhensible mon père ne comprenait
pas nombreux alors il ya deux pascal
sevran a que deux sèvres
il ya le parisien un monde 1-1 qui va
dans les raisons qui sont un peu comme
vous balancer un peu sur tout le monde
les propos moulié décide quoi alors il
ya le pascal sevran parisien et puis
elle morte héros les oies commande je
pense comment on dit d'ailleurs
ouais j'en sais rien c'est joli le
nombre de rôles mais marge rôle c'est
beau c'est joli ça chante un peu c'est
la mort 2 ans et profite mais il avait
tout à fait il ya le voir les juristes
très triste et très oui ça m'a beaucoup
frappé le mot mort dans morterolles pour
des raisons que vous imaginez et là où
il ya au moins comme au retour en haute
vienne pas dire c'est tout nord mon cher
vous la porte d'orléans pour vous c'est
la province pour sherbrooke absolument
donc morterolles 7 au nord de la
haute-vienne voilà voilà au nord de la
haute-vienne images il cela seulement
savaient pas de perdre
il faut trois ans pour revenir non c'est
vrai nom alors le mortirolo zouaoui
d'accord au niveau et muret comme ça
dans le silence dans la douleur ben oui
si c'est si vos deux faces vous êtes
vous êtes un janus s'est dit peu qu'il
ya plein de filles bien élevées pascal
sevran d'ailleurs sont aussi
réactionnaire l'un que l'autre et les
autour on pourrait dire vous avez la
nostalgie comme ça d'une france où les
oulémas son mason ou les jardiniers
jardinage l'esam tricote c'est partir de
bon on a expliqué très agacé par
l'histoire de l'éducation nationale on a
expliqué que tu les jeunes gens devaient
avoir le bac absolue au fond qu'on a
absolument dévaloriser les vrais métiers
je crois qu'on ait fait les délais
techniques modèle d'ordinateur tout est
très important sauf qu'on a fait des
générations de chômeurs et un jour là
médias nicole notât pourquoi ne
parlez-vous jamais l'apprentissage elle
m'a dit être femme charmante amy c'est
démodé
j'ai trouvé que c'était pas possible de
dire cela et l'idée imbéciles qu'il
faille aller à l'école jusqu'à 32 ans le
bac + 42 nouvelles chômeurs et paraît
ridicule
je crois qu'il ne faut pas décourager
les garçons et les filles qui veulent
faire des métiers magnifique comme seul
comme ce que j'évoque là c'est pas une
nostalgie
ouais la vie de tous les jours tous les
jours on a besoin de maçons de plombiers
etc
je trouve que cette sorte de folie qui
s'est emparée des ministres successifs
et surtout ceux de gauche
comme quoi il fallait à l'école a dit
dimanche pour en faire une génération
d'abrutis ça ne me plaît pas voilà et
alors il ya un truc qui vous indigne si
les épouses
je veux dire c'est que j'ai une très
haute idée de la femme et je n'aime pas
quand elle s'abaisse à notre niveau
soulève gm et assistance en pleure
maintenant avoue regretter les maisons
de correction
8 il faut dresser les garçons c'est leur
fait du bien c'est un fantasme que vous
avez à jeudi non je trouve que c'est
bien un petit peu d'ordre et un peu
l'éducation c'est pas mal je n'ai
beaucoup aimé cela il a fait un
magnifique là dessus c'est pas mal si on
veut trouver un jeune et par siècle
ça serait pas mal est donc faux à peut
dresser les garçons oui c'est pas mal
vous regrettez par exemple qu'il n'y ait
plus que des écoles mixtes vous
regretter l'époque où les gars sont
montés sur monté sur le mur aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que les filles se font violer
dans les chiottes des lycées c'est moi
je trouve que c'est pas possible non
plus je trouve que on le voit ça se
passe très mal
il faut un temps pour tout je vois qu'un
reportage autre jour 3 sur france 2 dans
sur les écoles aux états unis commença à
séparer un jour les filles et les
garçons se retrouveront quand il le
faudra mais je trouve que ça n'est pas
possible et et s'ouvre et là je suis
absolument sérieux il se passe des
choses pas possible dans les écoles les
enfants c'est très dur l'enfance et les
garçons des gens stress castagnet les
filles sont au milieu c'est pas possible
c'est une grande connerie de giscard
d'estaing voté par la gauche
il faut pas faire la mixité à l'école
voilà gad
je suis pour la mixité à l'école vous
êtes sur les matières les cours pas
comme tout le monde évidemment
moi je suis pas comme tout le monde a
son sens je ne serai pas habité par vous
ce soir vous regretté pascal sevran vous
regrettez les bordels
ça vous sentez-vous qui en est là je
vais le rejoindre c'est à dire que c'est
à dire que soyons deux secondes sérieux
là dessus l'hypocrisie qui consiste à
dire qu'il faut réduire la prostitution
est grotesque il faut respecter ces
femmes et ces hommes qui donnent leur
corps comme d'autres donnent leur esprit
il ne faut pas les mépriser
il faut mettre en prison et pendre les
proxénètes et faire les choses joliment
une très belle littérature sur sur les
maisons ça peut être très bien on peut
surveiller cela que les femmes ne soient
pas battus humiliés torturés
ce qui est scandaleux en conséquence de
quoi celles qui ont choisi sans aucune
contrainte de donner leur corps et il ya
des hommes qui ont besoin de cela on ne
peut pas être hypocrite sur ce sujet
c'est insupportable
donc je dis qu'il faut pendre tous les
proxénètes protéger les filles et les
garçons qui souhaitent faire offrande de
leur corps pourquoi moi je veux
apprendre du peu de talent que j'ai avec
ma plume
chacun a le sien je n'ai pas envie de
rire de cela c'est très grave et très
sérieux et oui en effet il faut
organiser la prostitue d'accord joliment
simon 9e du tout d'accord l'accès wi à
l'époque où il y avait des bordels et
des bordels de deux garçons y avait des
garçons mais bordel systémique jeu payet
ni rien
un petit peu c'est moins demandés ouais
mais s'est demandé comment organiser sa
présence est très gentil le commerce du
corps est une chose très joli quand elle
n'est pas contrainte soit il faut de
tout les pouvoirs publics doivent
s'occuper en priorité de s'occuper des
salopards qui abusent des femmes
ouais hein ça on doit s'en occuper et
pour le reste les femmes et les jeunes
gens font ce qu'ils veulent de leur
corps alors quand on regarde votre
bouquin quand on regarde la couverture
vas-y zoom zoom bon garçon il ya un
petit village comme ça qui rappelle la
fiche pétainiste de françois mitterrand
là la force tranquille et on pense un
peu à la france moisie dont parlait
philippe sollers dans le monde mais
philippe soler dit beaucoup de bêtises
oui la france moisie moi je ne trouve
pas si moisi que cela s'est beaucoup de
mépris pour les gens qui l'habitent
je ne dis moi je suis assez misanthrope
vous l'avez noté tout à leur jeu
considère pas que la france soit voici
qu'est ce que c'est que ces termes un
peu vulgaire pour décrire les gens c est
la famille 12 et vient c'est une france
nommé senior de france moisie sais tu
disais qu'on tirait salopards est ce
qu'il n'ya pas de francs soit 6 essieux
sollers à des fantasmes et france un peu
pétainiste comme ça c'est sûr que ces
vieux mons à 9h écouté mon cher thierry
vous êtes trop cultivé en politique pour
savoir que la france pétainiste était
gaulliste
trois ans plus tard oui oui d'accord
mais enfin il a été à une époque ptc
c'est la même
oui d'accord ça fait cher alors alors
alors quoi non mais on dirait une pièce
de ses incroyables
non mais c'est pas votre mentor c'était
manuel berl d'accord et bien est un
grand philosophe il ose attaquer quand
même et puis les discours de pétain même
écrit la terre elle ne ment pas je vais
les mensonges qui nous ont fait tant de
mal vous le dit très bien c'est très
agréable et baisseront langue française
les discours du maréchal pétain qui
était alors le vainqueur de verdun vrai
qu'il avait promulgué aucune loi
scélérate qui l'a promulgué deux ans
plus tard à vichy et emmanuel bayle qui
était la conscience du siècle le grand
philosophe juif quand on lui a demandé
de réécrire roja était en français les
discours du maréchal pétain a cru bien
faire mais à l'époque il ratait les
discours du vainqueur de vernouillet oui
enfin vous raconter dans votre bouquin
c'est pas un secret que je dévoile
pascal vous raconter dans votre bouquin
qu'à la fin des dîners chez vous ça ne
vous plait en s'attachant livni
déchetterie chauriens dreyfus il chante
maréchal nous voilà
c'est très amusant je fais amusant que
ça on comprenait gras mais vous
comprenez que des gens que ça fait pas
rire du tout quand même les gens m'en
fous quand leurs parents des dangers
dans des camps de concentration je
souhaite que vous chantiez maréchal nous
eh bien moi j'insiste c'est normal que
ça fasse pas rire certaines personnes ça
vous amuse follement je le sais mais
c'est en tout cas c'est beaucoup plus
facile et vous le métier dans un bouquet
je me gêne je ne je ne me prive de rien
je vous le dis ce que je voyais là je
dois dire
et puis je suis au tout tout soupçon ce
domaine oui j'ai passé ma jeunesse prêt
d'emmanuel berne
wen dans le genre antisémite c'est pas
mal oui alors pas de leçons là-dessus
c'est quoi non moi je crois que vous
êtes en fait un vrai mitterrandien ça
c'est vrai avec ce que ça de socialistes
et pétainiste
c'est à dire une idée de la france une
idée de des lettres
l'âme française vous dites petit ça va
vite moi je veux bien choses tout seul
me fais pas partir comme ça dans ce
politiquement correct qui m'écoeure donc
je ne peux pas accepter cela oui
j'aimais françois mitterrand je les
respecte et je les dis je ne renierai
pas ce que m'a apporté cet homme même un
même quand vous avez appris qu'il était
le pote de bousquet que oui mais pendant
la guerre il a eu la francisque etc tout
ça tout ça est vrai par l'histoire vous
ne sais pas du tout à me faire parler
vous êtes très bon là dessus oubliez
tout ça quand il a déjeuné avec bousquet
il avait là bousquet venait d'avoir la
légion d'honneur qui lui a été remise
par un tribunal à la libération fait de
résistants et de grands juif qui avait
remis la légion d'honneur à bousquet je
suis fatigué devrait arrêter cela est
vrai nom va donner à papon alors bien
alors dans ces dîners vous raconter ça
je trouve ça extraordinaire
vous avez un jeu forcé leur prochain
dîner oui oui je vais vous vraiment
parce que vous avez un jeu que j'adore
ça s'appelle le jeu du qui est mort
c'est un jeu très spécial qui est mort
puissant gens très cultivés y avait des
pas patrick besson et c'était tout à
fait les garçons là toute sa bande
d'écrivains du figaro ils sont très bons
les et alors on s'amuse beaucoup parce
qu'à mes cris est mort c'est très bien
on oublie défense des migrants
justement claude autant lara est ce
qu'il est mais oui il est mort gérard
manset non enfin presque
pierre messmer non jean-jacques
servan-schreiber
non mais pas mort non il est souffrant
ils souffrent raymond poulidor
non j'ai passé mon pays la haie à côté
chez moi andré stil alors andré stil
membres du jury de laquelle les
françaises la jambe arrière parce que
c'était le prix lénine ans arrive de
faire un truc extraordinaire et ma mère
lisait dans les journaux communistes les
livre d'andré style et je disais à
bessan autre jour est ce qu'il est mort
il m'a dit non ouais alors votre journal
voyage que vous et moi qui savais qu'il
savait non votre journal donc le
quatrième tome lentement en place de
l'église prouve en tous les cas un truc
c'est que l'homosexualité est vraiment
entré dans les moeurs c'est à dire que
maintenant ça me donne des idées
bave il ya des dizaines de virer du
vecteur qui compatissent à la
disparition de votre ami stéphane
circuler les bonnes femmes qui
d'habitude lisent les bouquins de hargne
et
nos de madeleine chapsal elles lisent
votre bouquin le fait que ce soit un
garçon ça pose pas de problème elle ne
lis comme si c'était une fille
donc ça prouve que l'homosexualité est
rentré dans les moeurs oui l'amour ne
pose pas de problème ouais et je m'en
doutais un peu j'en ai eu la
confirmation et ses questions à les gens
ne se pose moi nous sommes des pauvres
gens des hommes et des femmes brisées et
qui passons notre vie à courir après
cela et l'amour emporte tout en
conséquence de quoi
heureusement dans ce monde dans lequel
nous vivons en france
et ça ça arrange beaucoup au pays et la
jeunesse n'est pas pour rien tout ça ne
pose pas question moi je n'ai jamais
posé cette question d'histoire de très
peu important la sexualité la sexualité
c'est une affaire pour rigoler ou pour
faire des bébés
et encore le reste ça occupe assez peu
de temps dans la vie ce qui occupe
beaucoup de temps dans la vie c'est
l'amour est ce que retiennent les gens
qui veulent bien me lire
c'est la mort ou au delà de tout il
s'agit stéphane c'est exactement cela me
réconcilie un peu avec le genre humain
mais c'est la première fois qu'un livre
qui raconte comme ça là un couple
homosexuel séparés par la mort à un
succès public aussi important oui voilà
ce que je voulais dire oui voilà
l'homosexualité est elle mise donc à
linverse on reproche de plus en plus
souvent maintenant aux homosexuels leur
pouvoir moussa sow c'est ce que fait la
main avec vos merdes à la main le
travail du chapon le sait depuis
longtemps oui il travaille au monde fait
tout dire non mais c'est vrai qu'à quand
même un pouvoir gay aujourd'hui dans ce
pays non j'avais bien non du tout un
banquet le pouvoir gaiement aux garçons
c'est grotesque quand on a une énergie
quand on a un petit talent quel que soit
conçoit écrivain garagiste chanteur hou
hou hou plombier est ce qu'on vous
demande avec qui vous coucher à cet
invraisemblable on se demande vous
réparez vos tuyaux de tuyauterie de
baignoires et on ne se pose jamais la
question vous ne vous demandez pas si
vos jardiniers ou votre chauffeur taxi
aime les filles ou les garçons noah n'a
pas de sens bien en tous les cas vous
dites dans votre livre que vous avez
jamais remplacer stéphane aujourd'hui
vous n'avez pas de fiancé je crois qu'on
peut le dire
pascal un nom mais plusieurs oui oui
vous dites mais amants sont de passage
oui vous avez rien à redire après le
sexe dont vous préférez pas les voir là
vous préférez vous dites vous ennuie
la mosson contre on peut parler voilà on
se dit que finalement je veux jouir et
après dîner avec des femmes qui lisent
mes livres c'est bien c'est ce que vous
dites oui c'est ce que je pense
oui car maintenant donc c'est juste le
sexe d'un côté et l'esprit de la série
on ne cherche pas l'amour comme les
comme les champignons je veux dire
parfois on se défend la trappe des
champignons qu'on a vu ça j'ai entendu
ça quelque part je vous l'avais préparé
obligé de faire belle fille je voulais
être pareil non mais donc ça vous permet
d'écrire la tête l'ipsa c'est à dire
qu'une fois que vous avez fait l'amour
disons peau ben c'est commun c'est comme
boire à peu doué c'est une chose
amusante un instant bien pascal qu'une
importance vous savez pascal qui est un
grand classique dans cette émission gars
je vous regarde tout le travail c'est
l'alerté rose procès interview à
l'arthrose
alors on la parfaite depuis septembre
mais ce soir spécialement pour vous j'ai
ou faire l'interview alerte rose n'en
bleus ah ben voilà un garçon très bien
tout à fait
un de chaque côté comme à l'époque
dallaire toros voilà voilà
vous le connaissez quel succès vous êtes
très bien là bien alors pascal interview
verte bleue est ce que vous préférez
draguer ou vous faire draguer le faire
d'un goal est préféré embrasser ou vous
faire embrasser me faire embrasser
caresser ou vous faire caresser me faire
grâce à arette juin début d'érection la
plus belle
ainsi largué ou faire larguer largué
vous préférez un mec qui bosse bien avec
un infidèle ou un mec qui baisent mal
mais qui est fidèle
un mec qui baisent malbec et fidèle un
arrêt non c'est le contraire si votre
partenaire vous propose une partie à
trois vous préférez que ce soit une
fille ou un garçon
ah ça peut être amusant avec une fille
ouais comme quoi ça c'est déjà fait vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec 1000 mec
toujours de la même façon
ou avec un mec mais le mille façons
différentes je pas obsédé par ça du tout
c'est d'abord ça n'amuse très peu de
temps oui bah je sais pas moi prenez du
viagra
bon ça l'a très bien
comme souvent faire du halal
garçons
[Applaudissements]
attaque
allah
18 ans la ville était beau comme m
[Musique]
voici pascal sevran et allan
à
voilà pascal sevran et alan je vois je
vois tu as call que vous portez votre
légion d'honneur
oui je trouve pour venir chez toi ça
faisait plus chez bien on peut voir doit
réussir de guerre bon on peut voir votre
blessure de kaka le mérite agricole non
pourquoi pas je viens alors résumé des
épisodes précédents pascal a organisé
sur france 2 un concours de chanteurs et
de chanteuses intitulé entrée d'artistes
5000 candidats 400 audition 40
sélectionné quatorze finalistes et un
vainqueur allan
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
garçons
[Musique]
villemin
en france des enfants qui sont sains
quand
tous les enfants
ok pour les quatre 1999 ça nous aide de
boucherie la sélection écoute bien le
début
oui
le défi
les filles aiment défi à l'âme j'ai bien
compris parce qu'à fille et mes filles
c'est une chanson qui a créé des leaders
ya trente ans que françois ozon a repris
dans son film et kahlan a entendu dans
ce sens ce film est ma prose et de la
chanter chansons ont créé par dalida qui
n'avait pas exactement son âge à ce
moment là et j'ai été étonné le voir
qu'il avait choisi cette chanson il la
chante et je trouve qu'elle est beaucoup
de l'intensité les téléspectateurs l'ont
pensé aussi je continue à le penser
voilà quand tu es sérieux que j'adore je
me dis que tu me pose une question je te
réponds voilà d'accord t'as pas la voix
de mon physique mais tu as une belle
voix mais t'as pas la boîte ton physique
[Musique]
ouais temps pour ne pas vivre seul des
filles aiment des filles de notre faute
voilà c'est ça qu'ils entendent et c'est
vachement bien je ne sais pas si tu as
quel âge à la ddt j'ai 17 ans à penser
des trucs des gens voilà alors ce
morceau ce morceau ce morceau est
extrait de la compil officiel entrée
d'artistes vous connaissez orlando halal
je le connais oui un petit peu puisque
je connais un petit peu le parcours
d'hélène ségara way est donc un landau
forcément vous savez qu orlando exige le
clip vous savez ça vous vous tenez comme
mitterrand il ya des références plus
déplaisante que celle là non je n'en ai
pas c'est pareil pourquoi bah oui c'est
juste pour montrer que je me le d'orange
aller à la racine solutré avec ou ctv
pour dire cher bruno gaccio tout le
monde le sait bien sûr mais pourquoi
c'est sa fidélité à différents sonore
voilà si sa fidélité à mitterrand sa
mère la mère supposée si donc vous allez
regarder votre caméra à la main et vous
allez dire magnéto serge magnéto serge
[Musique]
alors vous vous êtes le vainqueur
à treize finalistes qui reprennent les
grands succès de la chanson française
sur cette compil entrée d'artistes est
le clip il est ratée sans déconner c'est
pas un clip c'est un extrait les
initiants blanc pascal quand je pense
qu'on vous reprocher de de faire chanter
que des vieillards finalement fait
mentir la légende
ben vous voyez on avait tort ouais j'ai
toujours tout au long de l'exécution t
vient jeter plus longtemps j'ai fait
chanter toutes les générations et est
donc maintenant on y refait j'ai fait le
chantre et aussi à changer de jeunes je
pensais que tu avais l'air content qu
est ce que tu as donc c'est à dire que
je ne sais pas tellement je suis venu en
voisin
et comme tu me l'affairé métiers de
demain vite et j'étais content de venir
pour alan passé impressionnant pour
laisser première émission de télévision
car quoi qu'on dise je crois qu'à très
grand tempérament chez ce garçon et donc
je suis venu parce que tu m'as fait la
gentillesse de l'inviter d'invités sans
ça je vais très peu d'émissions de
télévision comme tu le sais et je n'ai
pas du tout envie de venir faire des
gugusses rit donc je réponds aux
questions que tu me poses
mais s'il s'agit de faire le clown ça
n'est pas mon métier auquel pendant
longtemps incompris oui alors arrête de
nous arrêter c'est pas non plus une
raison pour faire la gueule je veux dire
je ne fais pas la gueule je réponds à
tes questions avec plaisir je suis
content d'être là j'écoute tes questions
vous et moi ici s'agit palladium
existait super-six s'agit s'il s'agit de
ce petit jeu là je connais par coeur je
connaissais depuis longtemps sa
télévision
c'est bien s'amuse aussi mais quand je
suis chez moi va je zappe un petit peu
mais ça me fatigue un peu
un don de baziège et écoute je réponds à
ce que tu veux parce qu'en général ces
questions sont pas forcément stupide
bien compris
alors
pascal vous allez écrire une chanson
pour le premier album un sourire à
bon j'ai eu mon premier sourire sa bien
aimée je la donne regarde les yeux qui
la jeunesse ont tourné ensemble qu'on
boit du vin blanc car littérature et
politique et ce soir n'est lui parler un
peu chanson oui je ne vais pas
d'exaspérer longtemps pose moi ta
question je réponds maintenant pas
d'accord alors la question c'est pascal
simon pas une question d'ailleurs vous
allez écrire une chanson pour le premier
album de dahlan ça fait longtemps que
vous n'avez pas écrit de chansons moi je
n'ai pas écrit de chansons depuis très
longtemps je ne suis pas sûr que je vais
en écrire
voilà donc peut-être à une chanson c'est
pas l'objet je ne suis pas le producteur
de la tournée je suis pas le producteur
de disques c'est pas l'auteur des
chansons suis là je suis l'homme qui
fait de son mieux pour cent les services
publics ouvrir une fenêtre sur une
génération
ils sont pas mal c'est simple dit
alors
vous avez déclaré en parlant d' alan ils
brûlent d'un feu intérieur et ça se voit
quand il sourit oui vous savez il y
avait comme ça 7 500 audition et puis à
un moment donné voilà on se dit c'est
lui ou c'est elle est évidemment c'était
lui voilà je ne suis pas absolument
abrutis quand je parle de chanteurs
aussi intéressante bruno gaccio
quand ils parlent de liberté
d'expression est aussi drôle alors alan
ont parlé d' alan maintenant à l'âne
vous êtes originaire de la somme d'un
petit village qui s'appelle friville
escarbotin et maintenant tu es à paris
4126 habitants voilà vos parents michel
et michel possède une petite entreprise
de rondelle alors tous les leviers voilà
ses dépenses et personne me dire avec
explique vasile cintrée tubes en fait à
fond la revue montré des rares cas pas
le père chanteur ou la mère chanteurs
comédiens et des lymphomes affaire qui
fait les tubes donc c'est bien pour lui
[Applaudissements]
encore trois quarts d'heure il fait des
vannes secondes
sourit fed et j'honore famille quand
même deux musiciens votre père joue de
la guitare et du trombone votre
grand-père du saxophone boxeur du pipeau
savoir pareil que précédemment on les
pense alors quand vous apprenez
l'existence du casting de pascal sevran
vous hésitez pas ce que voulait pas
commencer par la télévision pourquoi ce
que gérant jamais couru les castings
j'émettrais été très attiré par ça et
j'ai tenté ma chance par presque par
hasard et je me suis rendu compte après
que c'était vraiment une très bonne
opportunité surtout chez pascal sevran
ans le jour du casting vous chantez
amsterdam et ça plaît pas parce qu'avant
il est très sec avec vous je suis arrivé
j'ai demandé de chanter il m'a demandé
ce que je voulais chanter j'ai dit
amsterdam una finances même chanson pour
toi évidemment quand je voyais ceux des
garçons dire amsterdam je trouve que
c'était une chanson trop grande pour lui
j'ai voulu qui s'exprime d'abord ce
répertoire à lui on verra après il est
et il est évident que il est évident que
ça me parait brel c'est très difficile
on peut pas comme ça voilà donc je lui
ai dit attends on verra plus tard et tu
as chanté quoi santé actuel des quand
même de patrick bruel gens font pas avec
trop chanté une mère de départ
je te démerdes l'écart elle a pas trop
mal réussi ni à patrick bruel d'ailleurs
autant pascal avait été sec au casting
au temps après il a été chaleureux nous
a beaucoup appris à tous à tous mes
copains
d'ailleurs des sons qui sont là derrière
entre copains très amis et c'est vrai
que depuis le début il nous a dit ion il
vous conseille vous conseille vous mais
quoi jeudi pour le collier riche en or
il a rien dit par le collier m coli je
remarque ici se sont habillés comme il
voulait je les fais ok puis sont venus
comme il avait envie de venir enfin tout
ça c'est les voir
ah bon bonjour
nous france
enfin tout rond
on ne touche en rien avec medion elles
sont quand même pas mal les styles sont
très bien vous laisse y vient toi vous
êtes la nouvelle bande de pascal sevran
vous avez vous changé quelque chose là
alors amsterdam 6 c'est tout à fait une
chanson de groupe ça te fait une chanson
green joie les amoureux sont 360 et
l'année
devaux la maladie mon époux n'est pas
n'importe où
ou bien bravo merci
[Musique]
ils sont pas mal hein tu te fais plein
de nouveaux copains avec cette émission
finalement ils ont très bien
ouais ils sont très bien le dis pas ici
tu m' annonçait la mort de quelqu'un non
parce qu'on peut se mêlent aborde la
chanson déjà je vais rentrer au sérieux
je veux dire
ils ont comme ça ils sont ils font ça
très bien c'est vrai mais ils sont ils
sont très bien qu'ils sont émus ils sont
contents et ça me donne pas envie de
faire de la plaisanterie là dessus voilà
supergrave
c'est grave sondés connaissent là je
hais les chanteurs de la jeunesse et la
passion la jeunesse et la passion que
met ces jeunes gens à leur métier c'est
en effet très important
donc je suis content de voir les
parrainer chez j'ai tiré ce soir à la
mpt pascal ne s'est pas contenté de
donner votre chance il vous donne aussi
des conseils alors justement on va tous
en profitent et pascal quels conseils
donneriez-vous à un jeune chanteur qui
débute d'abord une détermination
formidable c'est l'idée qu'on ne veut
faire ça et rien d'autre deuxième chose
ne surtout pas s'occuper d'être à la
mode parce que là c'est raté
complètement puisque à peu près dans
toute l'histoire de la chanson française
mais ils sont à l'abri de ça écoutez ce
fils et ma phrase parce que sans ça je
finis ma phrase il s'agit des jeunes
gens moi j'en ai rien à faire je ne
viens pas faire le bus ici je finis ma
phrase et je hais je vous dis que il n'y
a pas d'exemple quasiment de vedette de
music hall de la chanson française qui
ont qui sont arrivés en semoule en se
couchant dans la mode voilà alors vous
vous posez une question gsm vous réponds
du peloton voix oscille donc l'idée
simplement pas ce cas va les corps et
pas seulement dans la mode parce que le
temps ne la rattrape et elle est déjà
passé d'accord
quels conseils donneriez vous à un vieux
chanteur qui débute encore
d'être en bonne santé chanteuse toujours
temps parce que il faut il faut pas
employer sa vieille ces adjectifs qui
rit vieux vous allez être bientôt que je
suis depuis longtemps bien quels
conseils donneriez-vous à pascal sevran
jeune je donnerai un conseil à pascal
sevran queue à cette heure ci doit être
couché
bonsoir
ballack est
[Musique]
ouais c'est pas grave ambiant
tu la perds pascal seront mon pote jean
reno alors savoir chanter mais
apparemment quels conseils
donneriez-vous à pascal sevran jeunes de
continuer à faire ce qu'il a fait parce
que mine de rien il a servi la chanson
française une certaine façon en chanson
française que je n'achète pas et que je
n'achèterai sans doute jamais mais au
moins il a servi à ça la télévision et
continue sa part d'une hausse d'un quart
d'heure quels conseils donneriez-vous un
chanteur qui ne veut pas de conseils de
pascal sevran écoute parce qu'elles
souffrent c'est pas des conseils bien
est-ce que la lame connais bien la
chanson française vous croyez maïs
icônes et amsterdam de brel il connaît
la chanson française vient jamais toi là
tu fais alan allait geler ce type pour
d'achille et toi tu fais ce grand
monsieur
la cité compte sur moi pour faire son
baffie sur la plage de sevran sinon moi
pour moi tu veux un collier ahmed bien
est-ce que alan que vais bien ma chanson
française alan connaîtra demain la
chanson française est-ce que alan c'est
que charles trenet nous a quittés alan
ne sait pas que charles trenet nous a
quittés il faut pas lui dire pascal
année sensible syrie est ce que je vais
vous dire des gens comme ainsi vous
allez me dire mort ou pas mort d'accord
aller allons-y reggiani morpho et
heureusement mouloudji morts richard
anthony vivant nino ferrer mort bien là
bien il connaît bien la chanson de
georges moustaki vivante vibrante très
bien alan est ce que pascal vous a déjà
dit tu sais tu as un truc que bruel
n'avait pas à ses débuts ses jets de
l'avoir enfin pour faire déguster des
coûts de pascal baze et à la gueule non
je suis désolé
[Musique]
la gueule
non
ça va aller fais moi ton beau sourire
pascal je suis venu ici pour répondre à
des questions je parle de musique ok
donc je répondrai à vos questions
monsieur buisson j'irai jusqu'au bout
est ce que pascal vous êtes déjà dit sur
ton album je prends 80 et wav un jeu il
m'a dit on prend que je prends 80 et tu
prends pas et j'ai dit oui
thiery ces questions me demander mais
qu'est ce qu'un parc henri-casault
samedi ces questions sont très très des
raisons qui est simple c'est que je ne
suis pas le producteur je ne suis pas
l'autre je sais pas si tu mets tes mains
que mitterrand c'est marrant mais c'est
un hommage c'est quelqu'un que j'aimais
beaucoup il ya des références beaucoup
plus désagréable impression d'avoir déjà
vécu cette scène c'est marrant alors
alors est ce que tu as à la ddt
est ce que parce qu'elles seront vous ai
déjà dit attends tu vas pas passer à la
télé habillée comme ça quand même
oui mais je lui ai dit tu peux faire
tout ce que tu veux mais je garde le
collier est ce que pascal seulement vous
a déjà dit tu vas voir dix ans un gros
con mais au fond il est sympa comme il
ya des mots il ya des moments où il faut
essayer de raison garder ça c'est que je
sais c'est au maximum de faire ce pour
quoi nous
[Musique]